une scène chaotique des images qui
témoignent de la force des impacts
ce n'est pas un accident mais une série
de carambolages qui se sont produits
impliquant près de 200 véhicules vers
12h30 sur l'autoroute 15 sud en bordure
du saint-laurent
la visibilité est devenue nulle en
quelques secondes à peine
comme le raconte ce camionneur y avait
plusieurs comme sur un kilomètre de long
des amas de véhicule embouti coincé
imbriqués les uns dans les autres
le moment donné il me souhaite percuté
par deux camions par deux ou trois fois
le finalement revenu à l'arrêter de
nombreux poids lourds impliqués mais
aussi un autobus scolaire transportant
des enfants
heureusement aucun n'a été blessé des
dizaines de pompiers policiers premiers
répondants s'efforçait de sortir les
gens des véhicules dans le froid glacial
de longueil sainte catherine candiac
saint constant et saint-philippe sont
venus nous prêter main forte parce qu'on
est vieux procédé à plusieurs
désincarcération du véhicule
en tout neuf véhicules ont dû être
désincarcérés deux personnes ont péri
dans l'accident
il aura fallu plus de cinq heures pour
les extirper de leur véhicule on sait
que ces gens l'auteur répliqué dans une
collision impliquant notamment camions
citernes donc ce qui rendait l'opération
de sauf de secours rendent plus
difficile pour les premiers répondants à
la prairie un centre communautaire a
accueilli les gens évacués du site et a
permis de soigner les blessés mineurs
notre but c'est de sécuriser les gens
les mettre au chaud les north et dé
prendre en charge ce qu'est tf1 par nos
services
vu des personnes puis ils ne jurent
qu'ils ont eu beaucoup et qu'ils ont une
part de leur vie dans un accident alors
et beaucoup de gens qui vient de
l'extérieur et nous on est là pour les
supporter et les aider et même si le
ministre des transports estime que le
tronçon est sécuritaire ce tronçon n'est
pas
j'ai accidentogène par le ministère
après vérification qu'un rapport du
coroner en lien avec la viabilité
inverse hivernale n'a été produit depuis
au moins 20 ans pour le maire de la
prairie des questions demeurent sur
l'aménagement des rives et des brise
vent en bordure de cette autoroute
emprunté par plus de 65000
automobilistes chaque jour ici julie
aimant radio canada montréal